[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce 7 8
de sport sur TV 78 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce à magazine box un grand galet est
organisé ce weekend au Mureaux les
spectateurs notamment pu voir la
victoire de livinois Rima Ayadi la
championne en titre WB a continental des
légères conserves sa ceinture reportage
à suivre football ont joué ce weekend et
quart de finale de la Coupe des Yvelines
le voisin FC s'est imposé au tir au but
face à l'équipe de de Marly-le-Roi le
résumé du match dans ce magazine basket
ce jeudi 17 février les lycées
Sainte-Geneviève et Auch de Versailles
se sont affrontés dans une ambiance
digne des grands soirs ce sera notre
module découverte dans ce à 7 8 sport
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur TV 78
je vous disais dans les titres le club
de boxe anglaise des Mureaux à organiser
ce samedi 21 février la 3e édition de
son gala de boxe au Cosec Pablo Neruda
de ceintures WBA en jeu dont le titre de
championne continental de Rima Ayadi un
reportage de Céline Charles et de
Bixente Marion sentisteban d'un côté du
ring Rima Ayadi championne continental
des poils légers qui remettait sa
ceinture en jeu ce soir et de l'autre
l'Ukrainienne Olena Medvedenko
championne d'Europe des poids léger
un combat dominé par la pissiaquerima
Ayadi qui se termine par une victoire
pleine de panache globalement ça s'est
bien passé j'ai senti que j'étais
au-dessus techniquement et physiquement
que mon adversaire qui est championne
d'Europe donc c'est déjà top je suis
fier de moi franchement je suis fier de
la prestation après j'ai vu qu'il y
avait aussi des choses à corriger Rima
Ayadi se classe dans les 5 premières
mondiales WBA grâce à sa victoire elle
vise maintenant les championnats
d'Europe avant de pouvoir attendre un
jour un titre mondial au programme de ce
gala 5 combats amateurs 5 combats
professionnels et deux ceintures en jeu
le public était d'ailleurs au
rendez-vous pour soutenir les boxeurs
Ambroise Chris
on vient voir tout le monde quand même à
ligatier et on les soutient on est
derrière on espère que l'on fera un bon
combat mais après normalement ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'il fasse un bon
combat ils ont ils ont le talent pourri
il y a pas il y a pas il y a pas de
raison qui réussissent pas on espère
passer une bonne soirée voir beaucoup de
spectacles on vient de loin pour donner
la force
allez allez on est ensemble à Lille
fer de lance des Yvelines on arrive à
créer ce genre ce genre d'événement et
c'est clair que aujourd'hui c'est une
fierté en tant que président et en tant
que dirigeant du club je suis fier de
mon équipe je suis fier de mes athlètes
je suis fier de mes frangins parce que
c'est aussi difficile à faire ce genre
de plateau le club Illinois lance un
appel pour trouver des partenaires et
pouvoir renouveler ses soirées
prochainement
en football en jouet ce weekend les
quarts de finale de la Coupe des
Yvelines nous sommes allés du côté de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux pour suivre la
rencontre entre le FC voisin et l'équipe
2 de Marly-le-Roi le résumé du match des
images de Nicolas dandry
quart de finale de la Coupe Davis samedi
20 février Voisins-le-Bretonneux leader
de D1 recevez l'équipe 2 de Marly-le-Roi
qui est voulu deux divisions plus bas
dès les premières minutes de la
rencontre les cars se fait ressentir
avec cette occasion pour les locaux
quelques minutes plus tard le voisin FC
ouvre le score 1 à 0
mais les visiteurs reviennent dans la
partie sur ce penalty 1 partout
Voisins-le-Bretonneux verra l'un de ses
joueurs se faire expulser avant la peau
sur ce mauvais geste
on a rapidement marqué donc on s'est mis
on s'est mis dans de bonnes conditions
derrière on s'est relâché fortement plus
on a pris un carton rouge en fin de 3
mi-temps donc on s'est posé des
problèmes un peu tout seul on est dominé
en début
en place avec une défense bas et pouvoir
ressortir rapidement les ballons ça a
bien fonctionné jusqu'à ce qu'on prenne
le but mais on prend un peu le but sur
une action anodine
derrière on égalise carrément voilà ça
va ça va carrément dans le cours du jeu
on égalise à la fin de la première sur
un penalty qui était qui était justifié
en seconde période aucune équipe
n'arrive à faire la différence malgré
plusieurs occasions des deux côtés le
match se finira à 10 contre 10 un jour
de Marly-le-Roi se fait expulser suite à
un deuxième carton jaune un partout à la
fin des 90 minutes ce match jouera
finalement au tir au but les Marly choix
et choix de reprise
Voisins-le-Bretonneux l'emporte 4 à 2 ça
fait plaisir déjà on est qualifié pour
la première fois en demi-finale donc en
coupe des Yvelines seniors donc ça c'est
c'est une très belle performance
derrière le contenu on va dire c'est un
match de coupe c'était compliqué une
équipe de Marly qui n'a rien lâché on a
été bon on a mis un plan place qui a été
respecté à la lettre par mes joueurs on
peut être déçu parce que ça se termine
le tir au but mais dans l'ensemble du
match
on a deux divisions d'écart avec voisin
et on les a pas senti parce qu'on a eu
les meilleurs occasions on aurait pu
tuer le match avant si on avait un petit
peu plus efficace on l'a pas été c'est
les penalty c'est comme ça au prochain
tour en demi-finale
Voisins-le-Bretonneux affrontera plaisir
le 17 avril prochain avec un objectif en
tête remporté un premier trophée dans
cette compétition
on continue à parler de la coupe des
Yvelines dans les autres matchs l'équipe
2 de Trappes s'est imposé de 1 face à
l'équipe 3 des Mureaux l'équipe 2 de
Conflans s'est incliné 4 à 2 sur son
terrain face à vilaine Orgeval enfin
plaisir c'est facilement posé à domicile
face à l'équipe 2 de Chatou rendez-vous
le 17 avril prochain pour les
demi-finales toujours en football ont
joué pour le compte de la 19e journée du
championnat de National de ce weekend
Versailles demi-finaliste de la Coupe de
France a concédé le match nul ce samedi
sur son terrain face à Chartres un autre
prétendant à la montée le score un
partout de son côté laisse Poissy c'est
incliné 2 à 0 sur le terrain de
Saint-Malo classement Versailles est
toujours premier Poissy descend à une
inquiétante 13e place en tennis le
saint-germain-nois Arthur Riner knash a
perdu en demi-finale du tournoi de Doha
au cœur d'une jolie performance au tour
précédent face à chapeau waloff living
white était largement dominé par le
georgien à Nicolas basilashvili ce
vendredi le score est sans appel 6 4 6 2
Arthur rinerkness est à la 53e place du
classement ATP
j - 800 à 86 désormais avant Paris 2024
et comme chaque mois Grégory à Canal est
avec nous dans ce status sport pour nous
parler de cette actualité bonsoir
Grégory alors Versailles et plusieurs
communes de Saint-Quentin accueilleront
les épreuves dont la colline a
d'Élancourt pour le VTT le site doit
être réaménagé en vue de l'événement
sportif c'est bien ça c'est bien ça le
point culminant d'Île-de-France 231 m va
effectivement changer dans les prochains
mois aucune infrastructure majeure ne
sera réalisé sur place c'est pour ça
qu'on parle non pas de transformation
mais plutôt d'aménagement pour
accueillir les athlètes et les 15000
spectateurs annoncés le projet prévoit
la création d'une piste olympique de 4
km est dessiné par l'expert sud-africain
Nick Floro sel reprendra 95 % du tracé
existant une grande promenade piétonne
qui fera le tour de la colline sera
également réalisé en partie basse une
prairie sera elle aménagée à l'ouest de
la colline ça c'est pour 2024 Michael
parce que l'objectif c'est aussi de
donner un futur et qu'il ne tombe pas
dans l'oubli après les JO en 2025 c'est
la phase
héritage qui entrera en action la piste
olympique sera à conserver mais
compléter et de parcours intermédiaires
et facile pour démocratiser la pratique
du VTT un espace dédié au trottinette au
BMX au roller escape ouvrira en bas des
pieds c'est le pump track enfin la
colline sera pourvu d'espace de sport
détente et de loisirs ainsi que de
promenades pour les familles le site a
été pensé pour pouvoir une fois que les
Jeux olympiques sont terminés donc il
soit ouvert au public mais également que
l'ensemble des infrastructures
invisibles tout ce qui permet
techniquement de pouvoir très rapidement
réinstaller un lieu d'accueil d'épreuve
de VTT soit présent tout ce qui est
passage des câbles tout ce qui est
technique et cetera mais ça sera
absolument invisible permettront demain
de pouvoir bien positionner à nouveau
très rapidement un village pour un
weekend de VTT et pourquoi pas à nouveau
accueillir par exemple les Championnats
du Monde de VTT et où en est-on
concrètement aujourd'hui à Grégory
touche presque au but
pour la fin de l'année du 2 septembre
Yvelines en un peu plus d'un mois 113
contributions 228 avis ont été collectés
136 personnes ont répondu au
questionnaire cela permet aux 50 nuages
de transmettre leur interrogation leurs
inquiétudes et parfois aussi d'apporter
de nouvelles idées au projet
et le retour des habitants et bien c'est
la même la même orientation la volonté
de conserver un parc ouvert à la
population vers vertueux et donc un
maximum d'effort a été mis à été
confirmé par les résultats des études de
fait auprès de la population de la
volonté de densifier encore la
protection de l'environnement c'est
pourquoi les ce qu'on appelle la
compensation écologique sur ce site sera
certainement une des compensations
écologique les plus exemplaires que de
tout Paris 2024 et quelles sont les
prochaines étapes Grégory après la
concertation
public qui finance supervise et livre
les ouvrages de Paris 2024 doit
présenter un projet détaillé pour cette
colline d'Élancourt les habitants
par un vote cette participation a du
public par voie électronique se
déroulera en avril et mai prochain les
travaux devraient à démarrer à la fin de
l'année se dérouler en deux phases l'une
qui se déroulera jusqu'en septembre 2023
ça c'est pour la phase 1 l'autre
d'octobre 2023 à avril 2024 et
entre-temps en septembre 2023 un test
events Paris 2024 pour expérimenter la
piste olympique en conditions réelles
enfin la partie héritage d'ouverture de
La colline aux habitants est prévu elle
pour les jeux en après les Jeux c'est en
mars 2025 et ce au terme d'une dernière
phase de travaux on a hâte d'y être
merci Grégory pour votre chronique on
vous retrouve le mois prochain pour
votre chronique sur les JO 2024 on
poursuit ceux du sport par notre module
à découverte aujourd'hui TV 78 vous
propose de vivre en immersion le match
le basket des lycées versailles entre
eux Sainte-Geneviève Ginette et hoche
nous étions sur place dans le chaudron
du gymnase montboron décoré pour
des équipes regarder
le jeudi 17 février aujourd'hui c'est un
immense match qui se déroule au gymnase
de Maubourg
Ginette Sainte-Geneviève le lycée
affronte lycée Hoche dans un match
exceptionnel regarder
[Musique]
je suis avec l'organisateur François à
l'avant alors François expliquez-nous un
peu le concept de cette soirée bah le
concept vous l'entendez c'est un match
universitaire qui dépasse le monde
probable et incertain du monde du basket
c'est une fête c'est une fête unique
deux entités qui se prestigieuses qui se
connaissent qui se haïs pardonnez-moi le
terme et qui vont s'affronter dans un
match
un peu NBA à la sauce versaillaise il y
a beaucoup d'ambiance
et ça va être extraordinaire et
qu'est-ce que c'est à l'essence de cet
événement c'est vraiment l'effervescence
c'est ça c'est le partage on partage de
des différences
il me reportage des différences de tout
ce que les diversité
rencontrer des mondes qui ne se
rencontreront peut-être jamais
je suis encore des supporters à
devinette alors Tristan ça se passe
comment et ben on s'est entraîné depuis
une semaine là on travaille plus on a
que ça en tête c'est le match de l'année
on attend que ça c'est la concurrence et
clairement
le match de l'année est carrément le
match de l'année on attend que ça depuis
2 semaines en regardant du coup toi
le match de l'année toute l'équipe est
prêt on est là
on va envoie vous êtes tous maquillés
vous êtes en tenue c'était obligatoire
ce soir
j'ai passé à travers tout le monde et
tout le monde est prêt et concentré
depuis 2 semaines c'est le match de
l'année et tout se joue ce soir là
[Applaudissements]
alors Joseph on vient d'aller du côté de
Ginette ils font beaucoup de bruit ça se
passe comment du côté de Auch on a un
petit peu la pression on veut on veut
faire mieux que mais moi je crois au
lycée h on est à lycée Ginette ils sont
excellents mais faut savoir que c'est
une très bonne mentalité on veut faire
votre équipe voilà voilà
je m'attendais même moi je m'attendais
pas à ça c'est incroyable et vous
attendez combien de personnes à du côté
à gauche
à peu près 400 au total on a vendu 400
places en plus il y a les professeurs à
peu près il y a 400 supporters pour les
Sosh c'est un peu la guerre là entre les
supporters ça se passe comment en fait
Ginette
on va dire c'est nos meilleurs amis on a
un grand respect pour eux
ils ont des excellents résultats mais on
veut leur montrer que sur le terrain et
dans les tribunes on est meilleur que
maintenant place à l'entrée des joueurs
sur le terrain
[Applaudissements]
avant de combattre dans l'arène du
gymnase Montbauron les étudiants et
joueurs profitent d'un dernier moment de
communion en musique
[Musique]
une fois la musique terminée place au
jeu dans une ambiance bouillante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
événement attiré de grands noms DJ las
au platine le DJ les derniers Jeux
Olympiques de Tokyo
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi Marco freestyle champion de
France de la discipline mais également
Frédéric Weiss ancien joueur de l'équipe
de France de basket
mais c'est tout ce qui se passe autour
qui a été corrompre qui est intéressant
donc c'est pas la première fois que vous
voulez ou si je crois que c'est la
deuxième fois
moi ça me fait toujours autant donc
forcément je viendrai à chaque fois et
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît dans ce type de
rencontre l'ambiance l'ambiance est
folle il y a des événements entre les
cartons à hautement exetera le jeu est
important mais c'est pas le plus
important ça on nous a dit que c'était
peut-être unique en France est-ce que
vous avez sentiments là vraiment pour
moi c'est uniquement
je me déplacerai pas si c'était un truc
qu'on voulait partout pardon mais c'est
un truc extraordinaire j'adore
bien meilleur que il y a 2 ans il y a 2
ans là c'est beaucoup mieux au basket et
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
[Applaudissements]
entre Ginette et hoche c'est aussi un
occasion de découvrir certains artistes
et apprécié aller chaud à la mi-temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le soutien à fond et c'est trop
important pour nous et c'était vraiment
trop bien je reviens dans le match et
passe devant à quelques minutes de la
fin
[Applaudissements]
conserverons l'heure avant malgré la
pression de Ginette score final 51 à 47
c'est officiel Hoche remporte son
deuxième Clasico en 16 ans
résultat
[Applaudissements]
Ginette et Lambert c'est forcément
extraordinaire on est tellement content
de gagner au fond l'année dernière on a
plus l'organiser cette année enfin
donne-moi des concours enfin une
vraie dose de joie on a éclaté Ginette
là c'est merveilleux toutes les vrais
bâtiments sont contentes
et c'est magnifique ça c'est magnifique
voilà c'est comme ça on sait qu'on est
meilleurs mais bon ça arrive des fois on
a gagné 18 mois on peut leur laisser une
fois c'est bon on est beau joueur voilà
bon après je pense qu'on ambiance on a
gagné légèrement c'est un bon match
quand même c'était un très bon match bon
bien sûr une plante déception on y
croyait on y croyait à la fin mais bon
il faut accepter mais dans le cœur
François lamant qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire après une soirée comme celle-là
une magnifique fête des mamans de
bonheur des rencontres voilà je partage
du partage
ouais je la vois brisée mais j'ai pas
cours demain vous étiez un coach de
Ginette ce soir pas trop déçu quand même
oui un peu déçu mais le plus beau c'est
que la fête soit magnifique est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que l'événement
prend de plus en plus ampleur d'aller en
année
incroyable demande tout le monde veut y
être les joueurs la presse voilà toutes
les directions
90 profs je sais pas quoi vous dire mais
j'ai le cœur le cœur rempli
on peut pas mettre plus de place c'était
plus de star tu sais plus de moyens
humains
je sais pas aller ailleurs mais je tiens
à rester à Versailles parce que beaucoup
de beaucoup de club nous proposent ici
pardon ce match mais on est quand même
très fidèle à Versailles mots peut-être
vive le partage vive les excellence vive
les diversités merci François Lavand
merci beaucoup merci TV 78
[Applaudissements]
oh ça pardon de Saint-Quentin 47 face à
Ginette rendez-vous l'année prochaine
pour de nouvelles aventures
encore un grand bravo à Auch pour ça à
victoire face à Ginette un rendez-vous
maintenant à noter dans vos agendas et
nouvelle édition de la diagonale des
Yvelines est programmée le 2 avril
prochain l'événement permet de traverser
le département entre elles par des
chemins à forestiers les organisateurs
attendent près de 500 personnes pour
l'événement l'écoute l'un des
organisateurs au micro de TV 78 c'est
une interview express
[Musique]
les Yvelines c'est c'est un trail unique
dans les Yvelines et peut-être en
Île-de-France puisque
la prétention de traverser les Yvelines
du nord au sud la nouveauté cette année
c'est sur 100 km donc c'est un travail à
travers les chemins les sentiers pour
faire découvrir les milieux naturels et
pas très et le patrimoine des Yvelines
sur cette troisième édition
comme d'habitude il y a un départ qui du
100 km qui aura lieu à breuil-bois
Robert le 80 km avec un départ d'Orgerus
le départ du du 50 km des étangs de
Hollande qui avait été très apprécié
l'année dernière et le 20 km avec un
départ de Clairefontaine ensuite la
petite nouveauté c'est qu'on passera par
exemple dans le haras national des
Bréviaires qui a un site assez
remarquable et puis bien sûr
encore des nouveautés puisqu'on sera sur
le 100 km sur une poignée-la-forêt donc
avec des nouveaux sentiers des nouveaux
chemins et puis aussi une arrivée assez
majestueuse comme l'année dernière au
niveau du château de porgès à
Rochefort-en-Yvelines
j'ai une nouvelle course puisque à la
que 3 ans d'existence la dernière on a
eu on a quand même fait 500 concurrents
l'idée c'est qu'à s'inscrire un petit
peu dans le calendrier commence à être
connu un petit peu la prétention de ça
et on espère l'inscrire et devenir un
lieu un endroit enfin un site
incontournable et une course
incontournable d'Île-de-France
si on peut rivaliser avec les contrats
mais on va pas s'en priver
je vous propose maintenant de terminer
ce 7 8 sport tout en douceur aujourd'hui
TV 78 vous fait découvrir le yoga à
Vinyasa discipline sportive qui permet
d'enchaîner plusieurs postures physiques
avec des exercices de respiration nous
sommes allés découvrir ce style de yoga
à Versailles en montage de Thomas
Rodriguez
relâcher la mâchoire inférieure
c'est votre visage
et connectez-vous à votre respiration
Johanna invite ses élèves à lâcher prise
pour réaliser au mieux leurs séances de
yoga vigne à ça depuis une dizaine
d'années cette Versailles pratique c'est
discipline développée au cours du 20e
siècle
en musique souvent qui est un petit peu
plus dynamique puisque en fait on
enchaîne les postures au rythme de la
respiration donc on va les tenir un peu
moins longtemps que dans une séance
classique de Hatha Yoga mais on va en
faire plus et on va demander un petit
peu plus d'engagement physique vous
l'aurez compris malgré l'ambiance
tamisée relaxante les cinq élèves
présents ce jour-là vont transpirer
après un échauffement de 10 minutes ils
enchaîne les postures en rythme avec
leur respiration
expirez arrondissez on enroule le coccyx
le milieu le haut du dos on pousse sur
ses mains
plus de solliciter les muscles profonds
le squelette on pense souvent au
transverse qui sont les muscles du
ventre plat au psoas aussi qui peut être
en cause dans les mal de dos quand il
est pas assez étiré c'est le muscle qui
relie le fémur au dos et ensuite on
travaille aussi la force dans les bras
on travaille aussi la souplesse et les
équilibres après une heure la séance
semble avoir porté ses fruits c'est pas
impressionnant peut-être comme ça mais
ça permet de travailler l'équilibre les
muscles profonds et c'est quelque chose
qui est assez sportif
et au final pas du tout par exemple je
fais de la musculation à côté et
maintenant j'arrive beaucoup mieux à
passer tout ce qui est pompe on a
vraiment renforcé même le haut du corps
et j'ai vraiment raffermi à ma sangle
abdominale ce que je pensais pas du tout
selon Johana c'est discipline est
accessible à tous la professeur conseil
de faire une à deux séances par semaine
pour pouvoir sculpter à la fois son
corps et son esprit si vous voulez
tester le forfait de 140 € pour 5 cours
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]